bobasa acaba this ain't appreciated
though can't go Tokyo tomorrow
[Music]
Japan is weird and in a good way but
it's really weird sometimes
since Dragon Balls released in the 1980s
Japan has produced a boatload of
commercials with the cast of Dragon Ball
promoting various products and services
some even as early as this year and as
you might have guessed some of them are
kind of weird so here are five of the
weirdest Japanese commercials featuring
dragon ball I could find
[Music]
but what the hell is that is that gohan
forget Sal's unveiling this is easily
one of the most terrifying things I have
ever seen in the Dragon Ball world
Gohan means cooked rice in Japanese and
so the fine people behind Gohan Desio
thought it might be cute to market their
seaweed paste for rice with the Gohan
character from Dragon Ball but it was so
weird the first time I watched this I
didn't even pay attention to the product
I may have been a little too distracted
by those weird tumors hanging from the
site of Goku space
[Music]
there is something inherently unsettling
and hilarious about seeing these guys
swimming around with these red eyes
while trying to sell this really
specific product I didn't even know that
they sold these for swimming pools
I found three separate commercials for
this one product so it must be pretty
popular with all that said this
commercial does feature one of the only
times Goku is doing something fatherly
for Gohan so I dig it
I'm not sure if any of you have noticed
but dokkan battle really has taken off
over the last few years and can you
believe I've never even played it but
having seen this commercial that could
soon very well change their own boat is
that Jesus easy Nana or your font rip in
the water you can look out for yourself
I've never played toka embattled
personally but damn it this may just
convince me ever wanna see Frieza and
Goku with backup dancers and
choreographed dance sequences me neither
but it's awesome
[Music]
this strange but admittedly fantastic
commercial is advertising some drink
called max not to be confused with the
sports team though I could totally see
freezing Goku during a halftime show
strutting their stuff yeah that's a
dance freezer dance the expression on
this dude's face as he's using this
absolutely terrible product is priceless
what we have here is a device that's
supposed to give you the sensation of
charging a Kamehameha well judging by
their face they're definitely feeling
something see from that guy's walking is
affected but in reality this is just a
big blue vibrating ball it's not so much
a toy as it is a device for pleasuring
enormous creatures like elephants whales
and your mom these commercials are
absolutely insane but then again so is
Dragonball and these are just some of
the crazy commercials Dragonball has out
there which ones were your favorites did
I forget to include one let me know down
below if you like this video don't
forget to leave a like and maybe check
out these videos for more totally not
mark Dragonball goodness but they'll do
it for this week thank you so much for
watching
you